[Music]
once again the media wetting themselves
with excitement over Trump's third
indictment the orange Menace getting hit
with four new charges from the special
counsel this time over questioning the
outcome of the 2020 election the case
seems pretty flimsy but the Talking
Heads claim it's worse than Watergate
911 and the Civil War combined
it is one of if not the most significant
case in United States history 9 11 2001
Osama Bin Laden another terrorists hated
our democracy try to destroy it Donald
Trump just like those other threats to
American democracy tried to destroy our
system this is the gravest political
crime since secession this has a chance
of going to trial before the election
and that's exactly what Jack Smith did
he he knows what he's doing and he did
it here this case can be tried before
the election I don't see any reason why
it shouldn't the election will be simply
about where Will trump serve his next
term in the white house or in the big
house yeah so they want to send Trump to
the big house before you voters even get
the chance to send him back to the White
House
legal experts and Republicans argue this
indictment is an attack on the First
Amendment political speech now has been
criminalized the first amendment is
under assault it's under attack by the
Biden Administration you see a lot of
deceitful conduct but the problem I
think Jack Smith has is that Congress
has not enacted statutes that that
directly
criminalized the the behavior that Smith
is talking about when I take a red pen
through a material that is protected by
the First Amendment it reduces much of
this to a haiku and Republicans are
blasting how Trump's new legal troubles
are once again perfect timing for the
bidens notice the difference on how the
media covers Joe's growing scandals you
just can't equate these two things I
mean you're talking about an
encyclopedia of outrages and Scandals
against constitutional government versus
what's you know at best a comma or a
footnote in the annals of American
political history because you're talking
about the son of a president they talked
basically every day sometimes Joe Biden
would say hello to the people in the
room if he popped in or on the phone or
whatever A lot of these uh relationships
operate in the gray areas intentionally
especially when you have somebody who is
either related to a famous person or a
powerful person or used to work for a
powerful person you want your clients to
know that you can get them on the phone
all right so Jesse you listen to the
journalists and they're relying on all
this hyperbole I have a theory that they
use that to cover up their betrayal of
speech and thought like they can't say
that this is it's about what Trump said
or what he thought so they have to
compare him to a terrorist so that way
they can then just crap all over the
First Amendment and their jobs
predicated on the First Amendment yeah
and they still don't want to defend the
First Amendment more people know about
the Barbie movie than they know about
January 6. to Democrats January 6 is
like July 4th to everybody else it's
just another day on the calendar and if
you talk to survivors or families of 9
11 of Pearl Harbor I don't think they're
the same thing some of these charges I
love it conspiracy to defraud the
government okay well what would you call
Russia collusion what would you call
Hillary and the CIA knew that it was a
lie still push it anyway not only that
concocted fake emails to make a judge
spy on the Trump campaign they defrauded
the fisa court also the laptop cover-up
with the FBI that's a conspiracy to
defraud that denied people their voting
rights or the CIA Psy up they ran on the
laptop a month before the election
coordinated with the Biden campaign
another conspiracy so if you're going to
charge garbage like this everyone's
going to be in prison I love this part
of the indictment when Jack Smith says
well
fact Checkers said that there was no
fraud I don't think fact Checkers have a
great track record so that's not even
going to fly in court think about the
margin of this election there was three
states margin was razor thin 42 000.
you're saying Donald Trump was out of
his mind to think he might be able to
claw back half that's what 21
000 that's all he needed to change out
and you're saying they're now going to
put the 2020 election on trial Donald
Trump is chomping at the bit he's going
to call witnesses he's got subpoena
power he's going to put Detroit Philly
Vegas on the stand and make them defend
the Integrity of their voting process
the lawyer last night was on CNN cleaned
their clocks the guy said they're trying
to speed this trial up we need maybe
nine months to a year this isn't getting
done before the election and anyway it's
going to get appealed and it's going to
go to scotus and scotus is going to
knock it down what the Republicans need
to do is time the impeachment because
that's the main draw and if you put up
impeachment with the Trump trials I
don't think the Democrats want to
stomach that um Jessica on the point of
timing I thought it was really honest of
you in the Green Room to say wow having
this stuff come out right after the
Archer uh Revelations shows you how this
political Beast operates you know they
got greedy and arrogant and they went
too far how else can you explain why
they would do it the day after I
couldn't believe you said that you
always betray yourself because you go
one step too far like maybe like a
Democrat
not at all
um I think that the timing of this feels
that way to people who think that Donald
Trump is innocent in of all things but
the fact of the matter is is that there
is such a Litany of crimes that he has
committed all over the country that it
just adds up this way that you're going
to have another indictment and then
you're gonna have another one so carry
on Republicans with your investigations
of Joe Biden and Hunter Biden and Jack
Smith will continue his work in these
grand juries which by the way are not
people who work at the doj they're
regular people like in Florida and in DC
and in New York
yes do you see in New York that's how
you win an election the idea that you
can only get a fair trial if people have
the same political beliefs as you is
patently absurd I mean then it's just
like okay Donald Trump can only go
before white billionaire Republicans so
that's so I guess you don't need lawyers
to look at juries then
[Music]
Amendment and Jack Smith was very
careful to make sure that the way that
this indictment was laid out made it so
that speech continued to be protected
Donald Trump had every right to continue
to say this is fake there's fraud blah
blah blah what he didn't have a right to
do was to act on it and that's where the
crimes were actually committed so what
is new in this indictment versus the
January 6 committee work is Mike Pence
is a big part of this so he took copious
notes through the entire process which
includes a conversation that he had with
Donald Trump or Donald Trump after
asking him to overturn the election to
not do his job certifying it he says to
Mike Pence you know you're too honest
when someone says you're too honest that
means that you want them to do the dirty
thing that you want them to do that
on page disagree with that you could
disagree with that but you don't arrest
somebody over it you can't disagree with
the fact that he knew that he had lost
the election because every time everyone
you're going to try to say that Donald
Trump knew he lost there's no way
they're going to try to prove that in
court Jessica there's no way he's going
to be proven that he knew he still
thinks he's president
well then the insanity defense is
available on page 15 of the indictment
for instance they talk about what
happened in Georgia and co-conspirator
number two who we know is Rudy Giuliani
now tells Donald Trump the defendant
this is a fraudulent accusation at this
point and then he still went ahead and
pushed it maybe just as an example
conclusion thing when shift goes in
there that's a briefing and then comes
out and says oh I haven't heard from you
is Hillary Clinton Russia collusion you
cannot move on with your life move on
move on this is a two and a half year
old story no it's not there's new
information we didn't have anything from
Mike Pence
collector scheme
electors and also some of his strongest
Defenders like Andy McCarthy wrote this
piece in the nationality which got taken
I have two other people at the table I
know I cut off everyone constantly I
don't know anyone can deal with me all
right apology accepted Dana oh yes is it
normal to announce that you know what is
in somebody's heads this is what we're
arguing about right now right so they're
trying to get in the that's why I think
it's so interesting because you can
think and I do that January 6 was
horrendous disgraceful terrible Behavior
wrong and you could wonder is there was
there a crime committee and then you can
read this indictment like I did last
night and say wait
for all of the things that they're
listing I'm like is that illegal like
one of the things they said you he was
trying to persuade Congress to change
their position like well every everyone
has a right to try to persuade Congress
yeah you can disagree with how he did it
you can think it's abhorrent but is it
illegal and the other thing is like I
think about this the other piece which
is I can't remember which charge it is
but I guess fraud the fraud piece so
George W Bush in 2000 and 2004 dealt
with Democrats who said he didn't win
the election
did anybody try to arrest them yeah no
nobody accepted the court rulings like
normal human beings right they did okay
but the other thing is this so Ruth
Marcus is a columnist for the Washington
Post and she writes from the left she's
a lawyer legal legal eagle and I thought
her column today was very interesting
because basically she didn't think this
case was a slam dunk she said I can see
where he's coming from and she does
think that something needed to be done
but was this the best way she just
thinks that letting it go without any
sort of consequences or punishment was
wrong but it didn't seem to me that
there was consensus that this was some
slam dunk case now contrast that with
the case about the documents where I was
like whoa this is actually pretty
clear-cut there were a lot of Republican
lawyers who were like that doesn't look
good for president Trump this one I feel
like there's consensus saying how can
you actually criminalize these things
that are thoughts like he passionately
sincerely believes that he won the
election yeah how are you going to prove
that he knew that that was wrong maybe
they'll be able to convince people that
when he tells Mike Pence you're too
honest maybe that persuades a jury but I
think it's going to be a tough road to
hoe they stay watch your mouth young
lady this is a family hour uh last word
to you Katie I feel like if you're
inside the story The Way Jessica is you
don't get the story but if you step
outside your bubble I feel like it's
rude if you get out the store out of the
store you see kind of a political
machine that this is what they do yes
and people watch elections when they
come up and they see that Democrats
before have suggested not just on
Capitol Hill but in the states and very
aggressively in the media that George W
Bush was not legitimately elected in
2000 2004 there are entire College
course is about how he basically stole
the election and had alternative
electors should have been chosen which
they're now trying to criminalize as a
result in 2016 the same thing you had a
number of people saying that because
Russia hacked the election that
alternative electors should be chosen on
behalf of Hillary Clinton and that it
should not be accepted when it was
supposed to be certified on January 6th
of 2017. and Jamie Raskin for example
who we heard from at the beginning of
the Bloc Democrat stood on the house
floor and said that the election should
not be certified and yet here he is
saying all these things about
criminalizing this Democrats better be
careful what they wish for they always
go way too far they push this for a
short political gain I think the ends
justify the means and then all of a
sudden their the rules are new and the
Republicans want to play by the rules
that they set they have a problem with
it we have an election coming up called
democracy Democrats talk about it a lot
they could battle this out of The Ballot
Box between probably president Donald
Trump and Joe Biden and let it end there
but instead they're using the justice
system to do it for them there was a
poll that came out in June of this year
and it was interesting it's from Harvard
Harris it said that 53 of Americans
would be okay with the pardon for the
documents case because they just want a
truce including 30 percent of Democrats
I think there are a lot of people who
are very concerned about where this
leads and whether it actually will tear
down our institutions as a result of
criminalizing basic things like free
speech and debate about elections I
don't want to truce Katie I know I want
I'm not Revenge that's what I think
they're afraid of yes like using the
Insurrection act which one people wanted
to do that includes you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else thanks